[Music]
[Music]
I said I was going to do something crazy
at 50k hopefully and that lived up to
your expectation huge huge huge thank
you to you guys I know I had talked a
lot about this on Twitter but big thank
you to everybody who supported me 50k is
just such a huge milestone and I know
it's kind of like a cliche for youtubers
to thank their audience when they hit
milestone I can't do a face reveal
because you guys already know what I
look like but hopefully this was
entertaining for you I know a lot of
people wanted to see me shave my beard
for some ways and I don't know like what
the whole fascination with that is but
everybody really wants me to shave my
beard so here I'm going to make you guys
a deal if we can hit 100,000 subscribers
that is twice what we have now by the
end of the year I'm going to go through
with it and shave my beard in the video
just a couple updates on things going on
around the channel I know you guys have
been waiting and waiting for the new
aldente creepypasta and I've got good
news for the people who subscribe to see
that there is a new all based a
creepypasta coming very very soon I
think it's going to be the best one yet
and I've got some exciting
collaborations lined up for future
episodes it should come as no surprise
that I'm also working on more things you
missed and we've gotten to the point
where the movies that I talked about in
the first couple episodes and things you
missed are now about to come out so if
you want to see me talk about those
movies again when they come out then let
me know down in the comments and just in
general let me know what kind of stuff
you guys like to see I've been
experimenting a lot on the channel and I
want to make stuff that I like making
and you guys like watching and the best
way for me to do that is for me to know
what you guys like watching so head down
in the comments
and give you some suggestion the next
step to me going to be August 27th at
can be at the same time it's 2 p.m.
Pacific that's 5 p.m. Eastern 10 p.m.
British summer time so be sure to join
them to them so that just about wraps
things up remember to subscribe to see
the world from the Newport every week
and remember 100,000 bees for New Year's
Day and I chopped off from Olivia you're
also going to want to wring that death
penalty notification if you subscribe
and you don't hit that little bell next
to the subscribe button then it doesn't
do anything for you you have a sub L as
well otherwise you're not going to get
my video source onanism
thank you again for all the support
thank you again for 50,000 subscribers
that number just still doesn't even make
sense to me I'll see you in the next one
assuming we've both survived
[Music]